Purple is a weird colour.
The formal name for purple is
magenta, and the weird thing
about magenta is that you won't
ever see it in a rainbow.
And the rainbow is supposed
to be the
full spectrum of colours.
So why doesn't purple,
why doesn't magenta
appear in the rainbow?
And the answer is to do
with colour mixing.
I've always had a problem with
colour mixing, because I know
that you can't mix
photons together.
So you can't take a blue photon
and a green photon and
mix them together to get
some other photon.
That just doesn't happen.
And yet, you can mix paints
together in art.
Color mixing is definitely
something you can do.
So what's the answer?
Well actually, you can't mix
colors together in physics,
but you can do it in biology.
It's to do with how
your eyes work.
For example, if I shine red
light and green light into
your eyes at the same time, if
I cross these over, you will
see yellow.
So when you mix red and green
together, you get yellow.
And if you look at the spectrum,
yellow is in between
red and green.
So maybe that's the rule for
mixing colours together.
You mix two colors together, you
get the colour in between
on the colour spectrum.
And we can test that again,
so I'll look at
green and blue together.
So if I mix green and blue
together, I get cyan.
And cyan is in between blue
and green on the spectrum.
So that's great, you mix two
colours together, you get the
colour in between.
But why, why is that?
Well, your eyes can't
measure the
wavelength of light directly.
So it's not like a photon comes
in, and you know, it's
200 nanometers or whatever,
and it detects that.
Instead, you have these cone
cells at the back of your eyes
that are sensitive to different
parts of the spectrum.
So when red light comes into
your eyes, there's a set of
cones that fire and tell your
brain you're looking at
something red.
So we'd call those
the red cones.
There's another set of cones
that are more sensitive to
green, so when there's green
light going into your eyes,
they fire and they send a
message to your brain.
And there's blue
cones, as well.
So you've got red cones, green
cones, and blue cones.
So what about yellow?
What about when you're looking
at yellow light, like that?
Well in that situation, you
don't have a yellow cone.
So what do you do?
Well, yellow is quite close
to red, so your red
cone fires a bit.
And yellow is quite close to
green as well, so your green
cone fires a bit.
So your brain is getting a
message from your red cone and
your green cone at the same
time, and it's deciding, OK
well, I must be looking at
something in between those two
colours, then.
And that's brilliant, because
your brain is perceiving
something about the world
that it isn't
able to measure directly.
It isn't directly sensitive
to yellow light.
It does mean that you
can be tricked.
And so if I make red light and
green light go into your eyes,
but no yellow light, you
will see yellow.
Anyway.
So, go red torch and a green
torch, and there's no yellow
light, here.
But when I combine them, you
will see yellow, anyway.
And TVs do this all the time.
So if you look up close
at TV, you'll see
the individual pixels.
And there are red pixels, green
pixels, and blue pixels.
Those are the only colours being
produced by your TV.
And yet, they can produce all
the other colors with this
trick of colour mixing.
So what about purple?
What about magenta?
Well, what should your brain do
if your red cone fires at
one end of the spectrum and your
blue cone fires at the
other end of the spectrum, but
your green cone doesn't fire?
Does it do the same trick?
Does is think I must be looking
at colour in between
red and blue?
When the colour between red and
blue is green, and you're
definitely not looking at
something green, because your
green cone isn't firing.
So in that situation, your
brain invents a colour.
It makes up a color, and that
colour, is magenta.
And I can show you that with
my red and blue torches.
So when they're combined
together
there, you see magenta--
absolutely beautiful.
And that's why you don't see
magenta in the spectrum.
You don't see magenta in the
rainbow, because it doesn't
have a wavelength.
It's just the absence of
green, if you like.
Just to show you the full
palette of colours that you
can see on a TV screen--
so you get red and blue mixed
together makes magenta.
Green and red makes yellow.
Green and blue make cyan.
When you mix them all together,
you get white.
So when your red cone, your
green cone, and your blue cone
are firing together, you
get white light.